ouch Gomez - how you doing you have such
great eyebrows as anyone said that we're
playing in D versus P PI as a game jam
where the instructions are to make a
game where it's fun to play and fun to
watch I just first of all just want to
say thank you so much to everyone who
participate in this uh I think it's such
a cool thing and I love any games I love
that I can support any games with what I
do and I love that any games can make
awesome games and gears adventure
miscarriage like just look at [ __ ]
titles
so yeah I'm I'm gonna play through as
many as say I've we feel like I guess
and we're just gonna have some fun you I
recommend you bros just go and play some
games and have some fun as well but
right now you can do it to me with me
when wid me not to me don't do it to me
peace ah man uh where do we begin
first game of today we have
hyper-masculine unicorns of anarchy if
the title is half as good as the game is
then we I'm think we do have the game of
the year in our heads let's play once
it's finished loading let's go baby
ah the rainbow club the coolest hippest
Club in the place
is that cocaine what the [ __ ]
ah yeah that's a good shape what the
[ __ ] what am i watching what the [ __ ] is
that nice balls what the [ __ ] and
tripping oh now it's fred phelps you're
coming with us
sinners they all went all but one
what slick the unicorn i hidden in a
secret fling and he's crying slick don't
cry slick my friends there again that's
x-men i saw what happens you know what
mate I'm all out of beer anyway I'll
have you rescue your friends me and my
boys are known as and feared as the ping
kit10 [ __ ] great white house unicorns
right even stronger when we absorb
demonic from this strongly balls weight
of Method Man so we should make a badass
team what an intro what a great [ __ ]
hit did you know that oh I can smack
women are actually ducks I didn't know
that that's kind of that's kind of crazy
my life is a lie I know what you're
thinking what happens if I jump in you
want to kill yourself jump right in
alright
[Music]
what is going on you guys know what's
going on I don't know what oh god the
nipple beer smack that [ __ ] yes that's
how we do it you want to buy some
shutup mountain are they spitting
they're spitting on me sup spit up
disgusting what the [ __ ] is that nice
butt though you done great mate that was
hyper-masculine unicorns of Anarchy 5
out of 5 for stanky studios thank you
next game uh what is this paddy pie
simulator well it was bound to happen
wasn't it look at his hair hello hello
hair are you doing there it looks like a
YouTube video that's kind of cool be
really where you do need be look I can
jump it [ __ ] that's amazing
I'm so happy I must be trippin out on
all those shrooms going on in the
background I guess very minecraft style
okay - laughs I'm always looking left
damnit that's pretty much what I do see
I don't even have to I don't even have
to commentate over this you'll just hear
him him Matt that's weird taste it it's
really hard
alright yeah yeah ah - Lance oh my god
what oh my god I don't sound like that
okay now I'm what dip hey I can jump so
high probably cuz I'm am high Wow
jokes ah alright we can do this bris ah
[ __ ] me yes oh my god shut up swear so
[ __ ] much Jesus ah it's my own
simulator game I have to finish it don't
ah I was just too hard
[Music]
this looks [ __ ] amazing look at this
paper night PT pie fight o go o go o go
go go get a get that go go go get it go
go go go get it get it get it get it get
it gonna go go go go go go go yeah got
boughs no got yeah yeah got got boughs
fight BD fight what am I supposed to
click what am i doing what am i do oh ok
I'm charging it damn it
Oh pity pie what are you doing I go okay
I have no idea what happened Sam sir in
D okay oh oh here we go here we go uh I
get his get his [ __ ] I know yeah
I want to be to PewDiePie he's such an
[ __ ] I think I get more points if I
hit the mustache yeah you can see how
much [ __ ] dammit he's laughing at me I
like either you sample love me the
Pink's it's awesome oh I got his hatch
oh so each item falls off I get it I get
it now oh this is amazing
let's get the headphones come on hey
what are you doing yes look at that I
have the brochure you leave it I didn't
see that it's awesome right I'm gonna
get that douche as boutique Mike oh it's
the bro freeze - I didn't see that I'm
gonna get the mustache there we go there
we go there we go
don't copy me PewDiePie alright well
that's actually I can't beat it but it's
a very impressive and cool game I really
liked it it's made by suricate games all
right we have another pretty pie
simulator just basic David Pitts
I mean I lied
don't you just love the music oh yeah
all right here I am just another day in
pretty pile and yes of course my
Mountain Dew wallpaper that I selected
yes and I better get to work I'm very
tiny let's see if I can climb up on this
chair there we go find the can yes my
god oh gosh hey the life of pretty black
people don't understand uh I got a
better turn down the volume please let
me just find the cans record ah stop is
that the can
what is the can academ sis Kaede serious
game oh thank god there's the majendie
oh I did it
ah what else can I do in the put a pile
and I can go to sleep so when I sleep I
shoot I dream about shooting cans that's
right take that can take that can why is
there always cans in my life I did it
I finished dreaming now let's play some
console games the play stadium 5 yeah is
that a microphone or a what is going on
okay I'm driving well I love driving my
car where I sure love driving man man
the graphics on the playstation Stadium
5 is so good that's enough bling for me
alright that was pretty pie simulator it
was made by Ripa and zonah thank you
rapid honor alright next game you don't
know half of it I can choose my única
form um I'll go with this one of course
yes and the race is starting I don't
know I don't even know there was a race
ah
yes yes ah
can we get much can we get much higher
ah I don't think so I don't think too
tired
[Music]
1111 which I didn't love was that the
game can i race I'm gonna race come on
alright alright so the game isn't
finished yet well whatever I saw was
sweet sweet a euphoria and we are muddy
muddy Heights we're hungry we want to
poop or so we have to poop
okay this is gonna be great
no [ __ ] way no [ __ ] way hahahahaha
yes I can control the poop
oh yes yes dirty peasants bathe in my
poop also I can be like oh my god this
is this is this the best game ever we
have some money let's buy some corn okay
and some gum which makes it bounce
higher let's poop we should aim for the
people on the other side yes here we go
oh god my poop has changed oh yeah I can
see the corn in the poop nice nice nice
bounce they're all running in fear don't
be scared don't be scared peasants I'm
just a poop damn it
I like how I poop without taking off my
pads - that's it's great nice bounce oh
right in the face right in the face yes
oh god yeah
oh god no he just had a haircut let's
get some hamburger and some chili
it's got out into traffic oh I made the
car crash wonderful Oh car what are you
doing uh okay let's try this some more
let's try to eat that bus okay look at
it look at all those people who died
look at that I hit the bird oh my god
yes ate the pie yeah Oh bus yes yes yes
what a mighty mighty poop best game ever
ten out of ten out of poop gotta love
the sound effects - oh no the car so
many innocent people died - gay because
it might poop all right I like that game
it's made by phallus solace
great game Thank You south hollows here
we are this wow I love how I walk I walk
with [ __ ] passion what is happening
what is happening are there shooting
[ __ ] at me okay of course Jesus Christ
is this a new call of duty what the [ __ ]
am i shooting are those drugs my rectal
health is going down dammit I need good
rectal health man I'm a machine gun ow
oh this is when me when I eat Mexican
food yeah best game ever 10/10 finally
we have the bathroom duck escape oh no
my my bathroom duck yeah where are you
going press Z and B to run socould
okay no okay I'll try again yes and then
boom yeah I like my nipples yes we did
it
Oh No there we go
look at those nips so shaking lips no
dammit don't be sad we'll get the duck
once in a while oh god no no no yeah ah
hell yeah and it's the cutest thing I've
seen in my life
run now
hey hey damn it stop I think I I think
it beat the game I don't think I can get
eight I swear to God I couldn't run
anymore
okay damn it alright alright I had a lot
of fun playing these games everybody
enjoyed as well thanks again to all the
awesome creators for being part of this
and I look forward to do more so go
ahead and hit the like button and
subscribe to come abroad today and I
will see you in the next episode say
awesome bro
[Music]